what you guys want to rap about the
Toronto Raptors yes auuu Canadian from
Toronto well congratulations sir is a
very exciting I was rooting for you
because Canada honorary Brits aren't
they really our queen is your queen I
think technically the Toronto Raptors
lovely is where I wish I paid more
attention to basketball this side here
what you want to refer unicycle gets
suggested all the time for some reason
that I don't 10 cents jet from twice I'm
sorry
what will you got hand over kidney
donation is this because you have
donated or because you require a donor
you require a donor okay um okay that's
got dark very quickly just have a look
around pointing to someone you think you
would work out from and then just look I
will pressure them into yeah yeah yeah
give us the kidney Wow well III hope you
I hope you get that kidney Wow
usually you know you close out the night
with something exciting not just like a
response stories Toronto Raptors yay
kidney donation sad let's get three more
suggestions oh wow there were so many a
whole all the one time did you say you
British is that where you said David
Cameron no you just said you said David
Cameron though right you're Argentinean
that's why
well surely you'd say Margaret Thatcher
if you're Argentinian yeah they're not
called the Malvinas mate they're good
well done if you got that to be honest
if I take the suggestion David Cameron
everyone here is gonna be very confused
so maybe will let's see well as we've
got let's get some from over here what
was that yoga let's pick something more
specific like some Hagrid's beard in a
yoga class I like it you said endangered
species
what picker specifically endangered
species once no you can't just that's
definitely the same person you said
Hagrid's big
alien versus Predator 2 was filmed in
the town of Gunnison where my wife's
family live not interesting or fun but
that's okay so what was in each age of
species we've got remember black hole
then on endangered species mate they're
making us an endangered species let's
get an animal surfboard showers was from
this same venue about three months ago
shut up okay
I'm fully aware there's some people in
this room who know I'm quite good at
this and so what they're trying to do is
test if I could if I will lie I don't
take the same suggestion twice what was
the animal black rhinos amazing so black
rhino they're on endangered species
Hagrid's beard in a yoga class kidney
donation and the Toronto Raptors and
let's get one final one the Oxford comma
yeah there's got to be something in the
rap for me that's the one for me okay
cool let's um let's this is the last
thing you're gonna see tonight so I hope
it's good it's gonna be a freestyle rap
do you want to roll that that'd be a
freestyle rap is make your so scared you
just made this noise turn that down now
a little bit you'll be about black
rhinos Hagrid's be in the yoga class
kidney donation the Toronto Raptors and
the Oxford comma and don't worry it
won't be as bad as were expecting it to
be you seem so confused by what's going
on that's okay I'll make it up the words
rhyme when I say let me finish like a
final in the NBA game six klay Thompson
slips well goes to hell break the side
that's the ACL Cady out with the
Achilles tendon if you're up front a row
stand to attention be laughing yeah
those injuries look painful waving
Canadian flag with that Maple Leaf what
lies beneath a bad movie but yeah
Leonard these are smoothie dunking that
still shooting threes from the arc I'm
watching baby fall in my bed after tour
not baseball I mean bball I drop the a
se
and pray to God that you will get a
kidney I hope you get one that's my main
wish I won't mock you no I won't take
the piss because that's what you need an
organ to do you got one function nipper
you need to you God donate that we're
going for the win she's laughing I
really hope that you've got win someone
the can't donate the frustrate maybe
this is mean and to hell I will go
straight I don't know but I've never
been feared
I'm wild on entangled like a giri's bid
when he's trying to look normal not odd
he bends over and does it downward dog
but he catches his hair under the knees
he's gonna tuck it inside his dungarees
that's a boiler suit that's the word you
use yoga my so absorbent thick and so
blue that's a fact you can check your on
my Instagram I'm really good with my
poses I'm a flexible man I could spend
my whole foot to the side of my flexor
yeah guy on the front row in checks out
he's lying this guy best to yoga hagwons
a giant not confused for an ogre yeah a
nice little rhyme that we spit let me
talk about a remark oh here if you're
acting [ __ ] but your words don't make
sense please donate or your attention
you should understand the grammar book
eat shoes and leaves if you don't put
the comedy and I'll grieve I won't
believe that you've gone IQ above a
hundred why would you remove it take a
it's plundered you've gotta put it in
before the final hand if you do that
I'll give a thumbs in with my hand and
say that that is good at last thing yes
I know I'm coming in stealing ivory from
a rhino I instruct remove the tusks I
wanna take it and bring it right home
with us I employ I take it overseas the
best dealer of endangered species black
rhino their raw savanna and go onto a
course or on a planter take off the horn
but then I have a plan
I go around the back of an intrepid man
I start taking out the rhino skin I get
my surgical gloves and dive right in
everybody's watching
this is crimson not just taking out the
Rhinos kidney you don't need this yeah
you are bigger I'll give it to you hi
and the last camping of people loved us
they enjoyed the rack let's finish now
there with a round of applause in a
clock
you